estos funcionarios de aduanas del
aeropuerto de orly están en el acecho
tras la llegada de un vuelo procedente
de cayena en la guayana francesa
vives en guayana no vivo en Francia bien
Cuál es el motivo de su viaje
familias algo que declarar no
el pasajero sometido a una requisa
rutinaria y un control de equipaje los
funcionarios de aduanas detectan algo
extraño algo pasa con los zapatos hay
una masa Blanca dentro de ellos unos 500
gramos
sospechoso es conducido a una sala
lateral más pequeña se pesa el paquete
que pesa 623 gramos y se analiza Su
contenido en busca de cocaína la
solución pasa de Rosa a azul lo que
significa que ha dado positivo en la
prueba de la droga ilícita está siendo
retenido por la aduana por favor
siéntese este hombre es sospechoso de
ser una mula de la droga uno de cada
cuatro pasajeros de los vuelos de cayena
intenta introducir drogas a cambio de
dinero
tenemos dos vuelos desde cayena al día y
cada vez tenemos a gente casi todos los
días casi
la mayoría de las mulas son hombres de
unos 20 años a menudo franceses pero
también tenemos gente de surinam Brasil
y los Países Bajos un tercio de ellos
han ingerido paquetes de droga la gente
que transporta la drogas se traga
cápsulas de plástico como estas si se
filtran el contrabandista podría morir
de sobredosis
una vez detuvimos a una madre con dos
niñas de 11 y 15 años que habían
ingerido 40 pastillas de cocaína entre
las 2
ese mismo día los agentes también
interceptaron de 7 kilogramos del
estimulante empaquetados en esta maleta
había sido escondido en un falso fondo
narcotraficantes han escondido la
cocaína en nueces pescado y latas
Al otro lado del Atlántico la guayana
francesa es vista por los traficantes de
cocaína de Sudamérica como una vía clave
para introducir la sustancia controlada
en Francia y por extensión en Europa
no hay suficientes funcionarios de
aduanas en el departamento de ultramar
pero hace lo que pueden detener a 512
mulas en el aeropuerto de cayena que
suman una tonelada y media de cocaína
incautada
la policía también trata de reprimir el
tráfico impidiendo la fabricación de los
gránulos
Mira Allí es donde confiscamos más de 4
kilos de cocaína
estábamos persiguiendo a un sospechoso
de varios casos de robot
le pillamos fabricando bolitas usando la
máquina con dos ladrillos de cocaína a
su lado
estaba fabricando para las mulas de la
droga
esta noche patrulla no dio frutos de Los
Traficantes saben que reclutar gente
aquí es fácil ya que la mayoría de los
lugareños viven por debajo del umbral de
la pobreza
cuando la gente necesita dinero y no
puede trabajar porque está indocumentada
o no quiere hacerlo es fácil que le
paguen por subirse a un avión y
transportar drogas
Las mulas pueden ganar unos 5.000 €
donde quiera que haya pobreza y personas
abandonadas a su suerte se convierten en
objetivos estamos la reformada dice que
se dedicó al contrabando de drogas
para intentar pagar sus deudas y
mantener a su hijo
si quieres hacer contrabando de drogas
en realidad no es tan difícil
tenemos contactos en surinam en México
en todas partes
por transportar 800 gramos de cocaína a
la Francia continental
acabó siendo detenido y enviado a
prisión
me desperté en la cárcel
me di cuenta de que esta no puede ser mi
vida
no puedo seguir así
tengo una familia una niña pequeña
si quiero que tenga buena infancia
necesita a su padre
una organización benéfica ayuda por Lux
a reintegrarse en la sociedad tras su
Liberación y ha conseguido un trabajo en
una ferretería